We are asked to plot 8 comma 10.
So the first number in
this ordered pair, this
is our x-coordinate.
This tells us how far do
we move in the x direction.
It's a positive 8, so we
move 8 in the x direction.
And then the second number
in our ordered pair is 10.
That is our y-coordinate.
That tells us how far we
move in the y direction.
Since it's positive,
we move up 10.
So we move up 10, all
the way over here.
And you could have thought
about it either way.
You could have said, hey,
look this is our y-coordinate.
This is 10.
So I could move up 10.
And then my x-coordinate
is positive 8.
So I'll move 8 along
the positive x-axis,
or I'll move 8 to the right.
You see right over
here I have moved 8
to the right-- 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And I have moved 10 up-- 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
You might be tempted to
move 8 up and then 10
to the right, which
would put you there.
But then you would have had
the two numbers mixed up.
You would have had the x and
the y-coordinates mixed up.
The 8 tells you how far to move
in the horizontal direction.
The 10 tells you how far to
move in the vertical direction.
Let's do a couple more of these.
Plot 6 comma 10.
Well once again, the first
number in the ordered pair
is the x-coordinate, how far
we move in the x direction.
So we move 6 to the right.
And then the second
number, the 10,
tells us our vertical
coordinate, our y-coordinate.
So it's positive 10.
So we move 10 up.
Let's do one more-- 5 comma 7.
So my horizontal coordinate is
5, so I move 5 to the right.
And then my vertical one is
7, or my y-coordinate is 7.
So I move 7 up-- 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And as long as you remember
which one is horizontal
and which one is vertical or
which one is the x-coordinate
and which one is the
y, you should be fine.
You could say, hey look,
this is my y-coordinate, 7.
So I'm going to move 7 up.
And my x-coordinate is 5, so I'm
going to move 5 to the right.
And it will get you to
that exact same point.
This specifies exactly one
point in the coordinate plane.